e aí
o quanto de investidores nós temos aqui
hoje
e quantos especuladores nós temos aqui
você sabe a diferença entre o investidor
ou especulador que atua no mercado
financeiro provavelmente já teve contato
com vídeos com literatura eles tentam
fazer essa distinção que seria o
investidor de um especulador a verdade
que não existe uma unanimidade e uma
forma bem simples aqui nós vamos
considerar que o investidor é aquele que
é mais cauteloso ele lida melhor com os
riscos na procura defender mais seu
patrimônio eo especulador é aquele mais
usado mais arrojado que em busca de um
ganho maior ele assume o risco maior
e no final do dia os dois fazem a mesma
coisa porque eles lidam com
probabilidades com cenários possíveis
eles trabalham incertezas e agora se eu
te disser que na sua vida você tem sido
o investidor ou especulador
ah e deixa eu te dizer porque isso é
importante isso é muito muito importante
começou para mim uma jornada que foi
quando viajei para nova zelândia tinha
oportunidade de morar na nova zelândia e
lá aos 36 anos eu resolvi fixar uma área
da minha vida na que me atrapalhava
muito pessoalmente eu tinha um projeto é
família filhos e ainda tava solteiro e
eu era um desastre para chegar no almoço
e uma menina e começar a puxar um papo
eu era tão ruim na hora que eu aviso tá
uma festa um colega meu de faculdade
chegou para mim falou assim ó e vou lá
para conversar com o pessoal não escolhe
oito porque eu sou um desastre mas o
neném nem puxar papo esse era o nível
você tem uma ideia negócio era ruim
mesmo
e elaa nova zelândia encher a família
não tinha igreja sem amigos era eu por
mim mesmo né eu e deus lá no final de
você vai no seu pai eu vou resolver essa
área minha vida agora aqui e eu comecei
a ter contato com bem diferente do que a
gente consegue vir aqui no brasil hoje
ir lá meus primeiros contatos com o
corte foram na área de paquera então é
você ver a situação negócio é prático e
foi legal foi bem interessante realmente
comecei a ter mais autoconfiança e ele
algo que eu pude rever é provavelmente
você já ouviu assim como eu então por
favor não atirem no mensageiro aqui que
mulher gosta de dinheiro que mulher
gosta de cara queimou dinheiro né muito
patrimônio que tem um fundamento para
isso na questão emocional e não é o
óbvio não é o dinheiro material é que o
homem que ele tem um patrimônio maior o
homem que tem confiança na sua
capacidade produtiva ele sim ele se
permitia fazer escolhas
e penteados ele é mais autêntico ele
coloca mais limites ele fala o que ele
pensa ele age com mais confiança ele se
permite mais feliz com eles então nessa
oportunidade o pude ver como que a
capacidade financeira como as finanças
afeta no comportamento e aí qual que era
o segredo tem o mesmo dinheiro com esse
cara tinha não comunica ela já falou até
no ted talks mais vistos é você que não
tinha 16 não é fingir até conseguir
atingir até se tornar então se eu
conseguisse passar a mesma confiança a
mesma atitude se eu tivesse a mesa
autenticidade na hora ali de interagir
de conversar eu teria resultados
semelhantes a
ah e assim eu vi a questão do impacto da
da parte financeira no comportamento já
mais exibido mais encorajado ver algumas
melhorias na minha vida social e
sentimental eu comecei um grupo na nova
zelândia quero ou murchar não não mais
firme e eu trouxe para o brasil quando
eu voltei como não mais tipo do bh
atuado belo horizonte e eu tiver a
felicidade de um dos encontros foi a
tema de métrica financeiras e posto aqui
que haver dinheiro com timidez como eu
já falei no aspecto psicológico e eu fui
tratar não da técnica esse ficar até
muito simples era a questão emocional
então por exemplo quando você separa 10
por cento de tudo que você ganha para
doar para dar ao próximo e você consegue
fazer essa separação e e viver bem com
os 90 porcento você não tem culpa né eu
tô tirando do meu filho para dar para
essa pessoa estou tirando a minha casa
não tenha suco está bem distribuído você
sabe que já tem aquele destino o seu
senso
a missão de agregar ao próximo é bem
gostoso estudar uma liberdade e assim eu
ia falando dos outros aspectos a parte
emocional porque eu escolhi esse tema eu
tive um visitante que hoje é um grande
amigo a pessoa que eu admiro muito pablo
ribeiro e através dele foi ter mais
contato com o mercado financeiro quanto
tá as outras pessoas que atuam no
mercado até que eu tive coragem e
coloquei a minha pele no jogo e comecei
atuar no mercado financeiro e eu
escolhido que ele chama de fórmula 1 que
é o day trade isso é operações que
ocorre no tempo do pregão no mesmo dia
não carrega posições não fica o dia
seguinte e assim eu fui atuar com a
minha bagagem já tem formação em
coaching com programador né eu linguiça
e eu fui vendo e fazer algumas reflexões
no primeiro momento eu pensava não é
esse o mercado e financeiro imita a vida
porque é um mercado e tem ele a erupções
na liber
e aí você fazer as coisas e depois com
mais experiência que eu mais reflexão eu
fui pensando e se for o contrário se a
vida e metal mercado financeiro e assim
eu vou tirar algumas posições
interessante
e no mercado financeiro como eu falei a
gente lida com possibilidades com
probabilidades cenários possíveis e na
vida não é diferente chance som e você
algum momento falou assim ah eu vou te
ligar depois do almoço final de semana
eu irei na sua casa no final do ano eu
vou fazer aquela viagem só para esquecer
de ligar o seu chefe falar se olha eu
preciso de você você não conseguir ligar
é para um motivo não conseguiu fazer a
visita e por algum motivo mudar o
destino da viagem ou até mesmo cancelar
a viagem e por que isso acontece porque
embora nós gostamos de ter certeza
naquilo que ele faça a verdade aqui a
gente lida com possibilidade com
probabilidades o tony ramos ele fala da
nossa necessidade humana de ter certeza
na palestra que ele deu até nordeste
toque porque fazemos o que fazemos bem
explicado isso e a verdade querida com
possibilidades com incertezas
e é assim como é o mercado financeiro e
algo interessante também é a questão do
efeito composto a provar mente você como
boa parte dos brasileiros conhece o
efeito composto pelo nado lado negativo
da crise né que são juros compostos você
deixa de pagar algo e deixa pagar por um
tempo prolongado a tendência é que
aquela dida ela vai crescendo em ação do
tempo será que na vida diferente então
assim pegar um exemplo bem simples você
decide um dia para assinar vou parar de
ser sedentário hoje eu vou academia
nesta segunda essa vai e aí você define
que você vai ficar 6 horas academia vai
chegar de manhã vai se matar de fazer
exercício provavelmente não é saudável
você não vai dar conta chance onde você
se machucar o efeito e você vai ter não
é o desejar melhor seria se você
fragmentar essas 6 horas em 20 minutos
diários meia hora de área e assim você
vai construir um
bom então a meia hora de hoje vai me
ajudar com a meia hora de amanhã a gente
vai me ajudar com meia hora do dia
seguinte você vai ter um efeito de
acumulação também se aplica aos estudos
senhor e cinco páginas hoje cinco partes
amanhã as cinco partes depois eu vou
acumulando conhecimento e a sente os
especialistas eles são construídos a as
pessoas têm muita autoridade elas vão
acumulando hora de conhecimento olhos
experiência e esse acúmulo ele tem um
efeito um ataque cardíaco por exemplo
ela acontece de um dia para o outro é
uma construção de um estilo de vida de
escolha de alimentação de fazer
atividades físicas ou não então se você
não vai fazendo todos os dias você vai
ter um acúmulo
bom e o que é interessante ainda na sua
visão do do espírito composto é quando a
gente pensa por exemplo na questão da
série no mercado financeiro muitas
pessoas apavora quando tem o primeiro
resultado negativo às vezes a primeira
oportunidade novamente assistir o
batismo de fogo né eu entro com prejuízo
e aí bem aqui no mercado que muita gente
para fora e aí aquela saia né e na vida
não é diferente muitas pessoas querem
palestrar e aí na primeira oportunidade
talvez não se saiam da maneira que
esperava não tem aquele retorno e aí
desistem assim agora se ela insiste se
ela fizesse mais vezes mais vezes mais
vezes ela vai construindo ao invés de
considerar aquele primeiro resultado
como o resultado é imaginar que tem
outros que vão vir do mercado financeiro
a gente trabalha com resultados
aleatórios o que quer dizer que quanto
mais você vai ganhando mais chances são
de algum momento você perder e quanto
mais você vai perder algum momento você
vai ganhar
e seria legal se ele soubesse né nessa
eu ganho né seu filho mas é um resultado
aleatório e ao que eu guardo com muito
carinho foi a minha primeira sessão de
fotos durou meia hora foi um desastre eu
falei 29 minutos não deixei ela pessoa
falar tentava vender conte para ela
mostrar que o corpo cheira bom eles tudo
mais e no dia seguinte fui mandar
mensagem eu tinha um template esqueci de
trocar o nome eu chamei o josé de maria
e o cara saiu do grupo online e assim eu
comecei minha carreira e eu tenho muito
carinho com essa memória porque eu vi um
tanto de coisa que eu fiz eu poderia
fazer melhor e eu lembro dela eu guardo
ela compartilho ela tem orgulho dela e
assim eu fui construindo e graças a isso
é dessa construção dessa série de
resultados eu tenho faculdade ajudar
outras pessoas e outras pessoas
conseguiram achar carreira que elas
queriam né relacionamentos e outras
coisas nesse sentido porque a série é
melhor maior do que o resultado sozinho
o que quer dizer no mercado financeiro
se você perder uma vez e ganhar
dependendo da sua estratégia na
proporção você absorve aquela pele e na
vida também a mesma coisa eu perdi
aquela primeira sessão e na sequência
porque o mantilha constância aquilo foi
até obsorvido e tornou útil
bom então o que eu aprendo com tudo isso
primeiro seria como seria se ao invés de
você falar com absoluta certeza cima e é
muito tentador isso porque algumas
coisas a são tão recorrentes as vezes no
mesmo dia às vezes na mesma semana que a
gente toma como absoluto quando eu
voltar em casa eu te ligo quando eu
voltar eu farei isso eu sei que não é
legal mas vamos ser franco a gente vira
um país que é perigoso mas sabe que nem
todo mundo volta para casa mas a gente
fala essas coisas quando eu voltar lá
então existe essa possibilidade isso eu
acredito dá uma liberdade você não
precisa ter certeza das coisas entender
que existem resultados e abraçar colei
os dois resultados aquilo que acontece
dentro que você queria e aquilo que às
vezes vai contrário o seu planejamento
entender que você está construindo algo
e você pode fazer isso focando nos
relacionamento que são saudáveis para
você na carreira que você escolheu o até
o momento de rever aonde você vai
colocar
e o seu dinheiro as suas emoções do seu
projeto que você escolheu construir ou
rever se for o caso e entender que a
vida é uma sequência uma sequência de
ações download exista no primeiro
resultado negativo o que ele vai ser
absorvidos e talvez ele seja até
interessante na construção daquele que
está fazendo não é quantas pessoas
tiveram histórias brilhantes porque a
primeira empreitada deu errado né é isso
é muito entrar na verdade gostoso você
vai ter orgulho depois estar
compartilhando faz sentido para você
é perfeito então jackson faz sentido
para você que você entende esses
benefícios eu queria de fazer dois
convites hoje ok primeiro compartilhar
essa ideia compartilha com quem você
acredita que isso vai agregar na
qualidade de vida dessa pessoa quando
que você vai fazer a diferença essas
liberdades que ela vai se permitindo
nessa nova visão nessa nova perspectiva
de vida esse encontro convite claro
aplique na sua própria vida como você
pode fazer isso na sua próxima decisão o
seu próximo planejamento sabendo que
existem resultados aleatórios já colei
esse resultado sua vida e eu tenho
certeza que através desta aplicação
provavelmente certeza que provavelmente
as chances são e as suas a sua
capacidade financeira não seus
investimentos vão ter resultados mais
favoráveis e sua vida também vai
melhorar muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
e aí